you mentioned the start-up of PayPal
which is a great innovation that
happened in sort of how we pay for
things that seems to me an area in which
it hasn't been as much subsequent
innovation other than Bitcoin as it
should be
in other words quickly transferring
money especially to people you don't
know or whatever is to me maybe I'm
wrong far more difficult and it seemed
like it should be are you somewhat
disappointed with the way PayPal then
proceeded or you disappointed with the
lack of innovation in the digital
currency and environment yeah if people
has definitely I mean it hasn't moved
much since from when when it was sort of
bought by eBay the the long-term vision
that I had for PayPal sort of in sort of
finance was to - well it's it sounds but
strangely due to convert the financial
system from a series of heterogeneous
insecure databases to one database or
well not one database but maybe there'd
be like a few more the money is just a
number in a database that's what it is
and it's primarily an information
mechanism for labor allocation and the
current databases are not very efficient
like they're you know there are these
old legacy mainframes that don't talk to
each other very well have core security
and only do there and do vast processing
once a day are you glad PayPal is being
spun off it's probably the right move
and what would you do with it well I
think I think I converted into more of a
full-service financial institution so
you just you'd want to do all the things
that a consumer you want to have like
all the financial services that somebody
needs in one place seamlessly integrated
together and easy to use and I really
really care about the consumer I think a
lot of banks don't seem to care that
much about the customer so I think
there's not ready to be like a really
good Bank effectively but but but much
more than what people think of it do you
think Bitcoin will be disruptive in that
way and we're now it's a speculative
currency will it be something that will
be what normal consumers would use and
will disrupt the banking industry my
opinion but coin is that I mean I think
Bitcoin is probably a good thing but
it's it's essentially its main thing the
thing will be Haven this is probably
good quartered here in there but the it
it's it's I think it's primarily going
to be a means of doing illegal
transactions but that's not necessarily
entirely bad because you know you know
some things should be maybe shouldn't be
illegal so but the combination of Silk
Road and Bitcoin will save us well it
will be useful for legal and illegal
transactions otherwise would have no
value as a use of for legal transaction
because you have to have a legal to
illegal bridge yeah I don't own any
Bitcoin all right